long lasting battery is the most
important factor for Android users and
by extension developers should care
about it too while we want to achieve
reliable battery life or Android apps
should have some flexibility to run in
the background the platform needs to
provide consistent restrictions as Scott
Reil to prevent a few misbehaving apps
from draining the battery this is
important such that you can design your
apps to run consistently across devices
at the same time users should have some
control and visibility to app battery
usage how does Android balance these
considerations from Android lollipop to
pee the platform has introduced a series
of features that aim to offer power
management based on three main
dimensions firstly device idle state or
how long the device has been unplugged
and with screen off the device could
enter DOS where all apps cannot acquire
way clocks no job services and sync
adapters can be run you are likely
familiar with this already the second
one is based on giving users control and
visibility there are a couple of
relevant features in Android pea battery
saver has been enhanced for users who
want to have extended battery life over
everything else possibly at the expense
of some feature degradation such as
restricted location services during
screen off users can turn this on any
time or set it to turn on automatically
when the device drops below a certain
threshold so developers should account
for these restrictions and test against
them there are times when apps might be
too aggressive in acquiring wakelocks
or in general during things that are
considered bad for battery during new in
P there's the background restrictions
feature based on Android vetoes the
device monitors and detects apps that
demonstrate known bad behaviors and
flags to the users who can then choose
to restrict these apps from running jobs
alarms background services and so on
most users only use a small number of
installed apps regularly when you think
about it the total number of installed
apps
the device really should have no
correlation to battery life the third
dimension aims to tackle this issue
based on app usage patterns in Android P
the system can in a fine-grained way
apply restrictions to apps that haven't
been used recently apps are classified
into five buckets ranging from active to
never we call them
app standby buckets apps that haven't
been actively used for a certain time
would be put into an appropriate lower
bucket accordingly the system would
progressively defer app tasks such as
alarms jobs and network access further
the system uses machine learning
techniques from deep mind to
intelligently move apps between buckets
in order to achieve the highest
efficiency and it gets better over time
device manufacturers can adopt this ML
model implements their own or use the
AOSP algorithm various battery
management features spoil down to
restrictions and deferred access to some
combination of background tasks for
developers therefore it's important to
test against these restricted scenarios
let's go over some design and testing
best practices ensure proper testing
over a range of increasing restrictions
adb commands are available to simulate
the conditions you can simulate those
using these commands you can also exit
these States through similar commands
available in the developer Docs how do
you test against app standby buckets
since it's based on user behaviors which
can vary expect your apps be moved
between buckets always assume that your
jobs and alarms will be deferred and
ensure that your design can work under
those restrictions the good thing is
that most apps would be fine if they are
already following best practices such as
using jobs or targeting at least API
level 26 also note that in the frequent
and rare app standby buckets high
priority firebase cloud messages are
kept and any messages beyond a threshold
will be treated as normal priority which
could be delayed when the device
and her Stowe's again test against these
conditions thoroughly you can use a
couple of adb commands to to set and
retrieve buckets for your package before
running them make sure your device is
unplugged there's also framework api's
to get an app's current bucket or you
can use usage stats manager to create
the list of events associated with your
app which includes bucket changes want
to test under battery saver conditions
yep there are adb commands for that if
your app uses location for example you
can use this method to verify how your
app behaves when it loses location
services during screen off when battery
saver is turned on you can further save
battery by entering your you eyes dark
theme if available you can either check
for this mode explicitly or respond to a
broadcast in the event you need to
reflect our existing background services
in most cases the new work manager API
can be used to fulfill many use cases
use only foreground services for user
triggered actions and that users expect
them to run immediately such as music
playback by the way it's good practice
to also include a stop affordance inste
in the notification we've talked about
some design and testing best practices
during development and post launch
there's a couple of related tools the
energy profiler is a new feature
available in Android studio 302
currently on the canary channel after
you deploy your app to a connected
device the profiler shows a live
timeline of how your app uses system
resources such as partial wakelocks
wake-up alarms jobs and location
requests the profiler also estimates
your apps energy usage of CPU network
and location resources refer to energy
profiler documentation for more details
in the Play Developer console Android
vidoes exposes performance metrics that
are tightly associated with battery
usage which includes excessive wake up's
start
we clocks and background network to
access refer to Vytas documentation for
more detail with standard ways to manage
power intensive tasks and with proper
testing developers can create apps that
work consistently across devices and
collectively can achieve good battery
life for users to learn more about these
features and tools check out links below
thanks for watching
[Music]